hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled from Hendra to Wuhan
emerging back born viruses in a quarter
of a century this webinar is a part of
the ongoing corona virus virtual webinar
series produced by lab roots
I am Antonina salcedo of lab routes and
I will be your moderator for today's
event now let's get started before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the ask a question
box located in the far left of your
screen this presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Lim faux wall dr. Wong is the
director of the program and emerging
infectious disease Duke and u.s. Medical
School in Singapore we completed he
completed his bachelor's degree at the
East China Normal University in Shanghai
and went on to obtain his PhD at the
University of California Davis for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr. Wong you may now begin
your presentation hello everybody yeah
these are saline for one and it's my
pleasure to present this as a webinar to
you so it's titled from Hangzhou to Han
emerging backbone virus in a quarter of
century so here's the outline what try I
tried to cover today is a very quick
review of the major zoonotic virus of
either confirm or suspect with a bat
origin and then I will go to Cobie 19
you know it's really trying to say that
it's not totally surprised for
scientists working this view
and then I share a little bit of my
personal experience in responding to the
Kobe 19 outbreak and lessons learned I
have a comment tree that published two
months ago there were some right days
and then I goes through some early
events of the Kobe 19 outbreak and next
topic is on VARs origin and the early
you know the transmission events I would
finish up because that's now is really
kind of again in the media but I have to
emphasize that in all these outbreaks
are not that sport you know so actually
bats are started teaching us lessons how
to prevent disease outbreak and also how
to keep ourselves healthy so let's start
with the review so it's exactly 25 years
you know how to evolve in emerging
zoonotic backbone virus outbreaks so as
you can see from left to right 1994 we
had this Hendra outbreak Hendra virus
Audrey in Australia so it's a back to
horse to human transmission followed by
1998-99 in Malaysia Singapore we have
this nipa virus it's a back to pick to
human transmission then I think that
most people are aware of the SARS
outbreak exactly 17 years ago and then
you know I was involved to identify that
as the reservoir of the SARS virus the
SAS most likely jump from bats to civets
and then to human 2012 we had the Middle
East
whispers in German virus most it happens
that in Saudi Arabia and then
transferred to another 26 countries and
we believe camo is the intermediate host
and then you know Ebola virus is not new
by 2014 we had a much bigger outbreak
started in Guinea and so this is most
likely a direct that to human
transmission then you know late last
year early days here we have this Coby
19 although we still don't know what's
the intermediate host
most likely it's also a bat bars and the
are break as you know it's just much
bigger than anything else and we
right in the middle of the pandemics so
ever since the discovery of the vast
genetic diversity and wide distribution
of assad's related chrono mouse in bats
and sera jey evidence of human exposure
to sarsaparilla corners we we I mean
scientists working this huge have been
predicting more operas by assad's
related courses so I you know have been
working this for a long long time but we
were only half right because we were
thinking about cross related to SAS but
in 2012 you know so we see this is a
family tree if you like you know the
viruses are related so we can view the
tree so these are of course it's not an
exhaustive listing but these are all
traumas that from bats so Sanskrit on
Mars is here the red one so we were
thinking that you know people ask me the
question say you know where SAS come
back and we said sauce-like outbreaks
were definitely happening again so the
answer is yes but what caught us as a
surprise is that the most virus is
actually in a different branch of the
tree okay so if SAS can jump
Aniki of human and the most can jump and
kill human
so this basically present a picture to
say that if we don't change our behavior
then I think the more our break will
happen so we then modify our tradition
so there will be more outbreaks caused
by a backronym aus and SAS related
almost ready and more because we know
that carrots thousands of different
color roses so this is an interview that
I did in 2013 in strict times so that's
the major newspaper in Singapore and so
if you enlarge what I said is there say
you know I say you can Val I I'm almost
certain that in the next 10 years a new
killer virus spread by bats were
emerging so that's 2013 so we had a Cove
in 1920 19 so so that's like a six years
later within the tank
so suddenly I got right this time you
know who is Kobe 19 as a scientist I
have a very mixed feeling right I've
been warning people about this and I got
it right but at the same time you know
the outbreak is totally unfortunate so
what I have done to in terms of response
to this Kobe 19 is that somebody
commented that you're the only non
retiree ID scientists who experience all
major emerges and of ours from Hendra to
Kobe 19 yes I for the you know in 1994 I
was involving Hinderer and now I'm
involved in Kobe 19 whereas most of the
leading scientists in that generation 25
years ago would already be retired so I
was kind of fortunate enough to be able
to work through the 25 year career
secondly is hours on the ground zero so
I was actually in Wuhan from 18 to the
1480s January by accident means that I
had this pre-planned without knowing
that there would be a Kobe 90 heartbreak
because I have a strong collaboration
with the behind history of ROG and up
till there's three to four times a year
when I came back to Singapore then
before the Singapore government had this
quarantine policy I realized the
seriousness of this I went into self
quarantine and and during that period it
was good because I work from a home and
I was invited to multiple whu-oh in our
lives
II committees incredibly achoo Emergency
Committee which eventually declare this
as emergency of a public house in the
international concern and then out of
Singapore I'm also working on the
Singapore National Response he in charge
of the virology in a serology section
last but not least you know I think my
personal experience in terms of will be
on top of the development I have the
advantage of can read both English and
Chinese
especially the social media in Chinese
you know it was very informative
although you know it's a double-edged is
so there's lots of fake news there but I
think that I really have the advantage
can really digest those the English in
an Chinese media and I had plenty of a
time because I was home quarantine for
17 days okay so I just want to show some
photos really to demonstrate you know
for example this is when I came back
from Wuhan so this direct flight from
Wuhan to Singapore so was on January 18
so the photo on the left as you can see
at the boarding gate it's a very crowded
lawn cue as you would expect but 0%
wailing masks and then on January 23rd
the whole city of Wu Han was shut down
because by then we knew that there was a
human to human transmission so the last
direct flight coming out of Wuhan to
Singapore was on January 31st so this is
the photo on the right as you can see
you know the same sort of staff was
checking them people boarding but now
pathogens and the staff 100% wear a mask
so this is the big difference and so
during my quarantine I also have the
chance as I said I was working on the
teleconference on the debris Asia
committee and on the right I was working
on these reports in the papers and so I
will later discuss the commentary I did
a fall and set so this is the commentary
we wrote you know with three other
colleagues so the title is also from
Hangzhou - Oh Han what has been learned
in responding to emergency rotaviruses
so there's four points really we try to
highlight in the paper but I'm gonna
leave the folks on the inner top
straight the first is really cost
Posterous in the area of natural
sequencing you know costs Posterous was
formed more than 100 years ago and
emphasize the importance of identifying
etiology where you have a outbreak of
our unknown pathogens but they stay in
age you know we have napkin sequencing
so how relevant is the cost post race
the second point we raised is the Arbour
irresponsible scientific publication you
know as scientists you always try to you
know publish right but then your
outbreak response you know which is more
important how you get the balance right
so that's also if the relevant point the
third point is that what we are dealing
is emerging zoonotic virus outbreaks so
although you know what the focuses are
human and a desolate disease but animal
plays a very important role so we have
to use a one-house approach basically in
the veterinarians environmental
scientists zoologists and the medical or
had to work together I think we we still
need to do better in that area so this
is a timeline of major early events and
I'm not going to touch every one of them
just to say that you know the ratio is a
lot alerted on December 31st and I think
January nice is important because
Chinese come on whi basis they first say
that the outbreak most likely is by a
previous unknown of Crona virus and then
fast forward you know 21st January is
formal confirmation of human to human
translation by Chinese Authority I think
this is a very important milestone in
this outbreak before before 21st January
you know the world basically was not
taking any attention and the human
eastern China most people thinking this
is just you know another flu like our
break nothing series but after that
January 21st announced of the human to
human transmission the authorities shut
down Wuhan you know this is the first
lockdown of a major city in human sort
of mankind's history so the really
important there early events that we
know now at that time we don't is that
actually retrospect me now we know that
actually the confirmed cases have
symptom onset as early as December 1st
and some people suggest maybe it mates
earlier and then doctors you know they
order sequence E as I say the next
generation sequencing so the doctors
whoo-hah
some commercial sequency and they got a
preliminary suggesting that like a virus
and on 26 December and the doctors start
a social media posting and the
initiative was considered as Lumis by
the authority and describing confirmed
SAS cases as early as twenty seven
thirty said and the virus was isolated
on 5th of January in the hinds duty of
ROG and then the first genome sequence
was officially shared with the
belligerents 12 of January so this is
very very important because in more than
medicine the diagnosis and everything
once you have the genome sequencing then
the Diagnostics drug developing vaccines
or can start and then I think that it's
during our burlock these people always
try the question are we doing enough or
are we overreacting so there are lessons
you know like during the SAS times and
at the Chinese government we scientists
prematurely declared that chlamydia was
the etiology eventually that led to the
downfall of the Chinese Minister of
Health so that's why you know in the
media you know there are reporter
delaying of delay off who you know
reporting or so-called a cover-up what I
try to say is there may be this reason
that reason but the lesson that during
saw certainly was deep in the official
authorities mind if you announce the
etiology too early and it's wrong then
it's a false alarm but if you do that
too late then they also get criticism so
so this lessons right shall we continue
to report confirm etiology only or can
we do official report on suspected cases
right so next gen sequencing data is
very fast and very sort of informative
but this may or may not represented the
true etiology so there is a risk so I
think as the international community you
know we
or have to really debate on this you
know so we reported the confirmatory
only or one can also report suspected
etiology if yes how and when how do we
regulate right so this is a really
dinner the debate about shall we over
reactor on the reactor during emerging
our brief updates especially during the
very very early days and I think the
debate continues and so this is what I
think the genomic study can tell us
although it's a retrospective now so
this is one of the studies suggest that
actually that there are many different
lineages from the genetic sequence so
you can see that different viruses exist
and I don't want bored audience because
these paper is quite dry and a very
technical detail I think the important
thing is the message so this study and
together with others now Richard Speck
we just said the first known case is
December 1st
actually had a no market link so it's
not linked to do that you know famous
wine and seafood market and the second
batch on 10th of December 2019 had a
three cases and a two had no market link
and the out of first 41 cases searching
had no market link so the market
basically may play play Rory amplifying
the transmission but may not be the
original source of human transmission
and the other thing is that it's
important they really also observed and
doubly HR also reported is that the Kobe
19 virus is genetically more stable than
SARS almost so these can be good news
especially for vaccine development
because the worst you have is that you
have a vaccine against the kondakova 90
and if the bars mutates very rapidly the
maxing may not be effective so the
genera stability can be view as
advantage of a vaccine development the
last point is also important right
although we say the first confirming
human case is on December 1st in Wuhan
but the animal G human transformation
may have happen in
earlier because there are hypotheses
that suggest that earlier human cases
could be asymptomatic or mod so this is
to discuss you know the importance of
early intervention you know I mean it's
been debated internationally about the
effectiveness of lockdown you know so so
this is that the curve are full you know
new cases and confirmed cases and the
line you have there is the reporting
started on January 20th and we as we
already know that in a you had the
lockdown happened on January 23rd but
before that there is a smaller city
called chang-jung city and it's outside
Wuhan and the mayor made a very very
brief decision he actually shut down the
city on January 17th and the city has a
population of a million in Chinese
that's a small city where are you know
in any other western city that's a
pretty decent City so what you can see
is how effect it is all right so now in
this changing city they only had 185
confirmed cases and that you can pair
with in red another city sorry it's all
in Chinese but the the point is that
another city called a virtual city they
have similar populations but they did
not do early shut down and they have
1339 confirmed cases okay so we're
talking about a for difference for two
cities of similar geographic location
similar population only difference is
that one had a shutdown much earlier
than the other okay so now I'm going to
shift here to talk about origin early
transmission events so the virus now is
more similar to a backronym mouse which
is genetically 96% identical so suggest
as an origin link and most of our
me it's a bat virus but for most if not
all of the bat borne emerges an Audemars
usually there's an environment need to
have an intermediate transmitting or
amplifier host okay so we already said
for handler there's a horse and the
full-size is civet but for the SAS
kalaloch - or the co v90 in china we
don't know what that animal is the
animal our codes animal X so in the
media there have been you know
discussions about whether it's snake or
is it angry enough my personal view is
unlikely to be snake most likely the
intermediate host is a mammal you know
it's like all the VARs we have studied
that if they have an intermediate or a
transmitting host is going to be a
mammal so Pangolin is a mammal and so
what I'm trying to say is it possible to
be intermediate host but I think just
the recent papers published about
sequence I think it's not conclusive
enough we need a much more research in
that area okay so this is you know that
the Pangolin papers that have been
published recently many of them you know
and I think the latest the one now is in
nature just online
all of these are sequencing only so all
based on sequence studies and one had a
very simple Eliza to check the
antibodies and overall the genome
sequence identity around 90%
so lower than that background of ours
but there's a key part of the protein
that interacts with the wholesale
we--'cause receptor binding domain RBD
and the Pangolin virus is more related
to co v19 virus than the bat virus so
the current hypothesis is is that the
kovin 19 or those astronomers - virus is
their accommodation between the back and
the Pangolin chronologic this are only
in a predictions and the hypothesis we
need a much more data so this again it's
in Chinese but this is the menu you know
it's the Highland C for the host marking
behind before they were closed so this
sort of almost everything
in a except Angola but civet remember
civets was the intermediate hose for
SARS was so in that market so we cannot
dis considers as a potential amplifying
an intermediate host so now what I'm
trying to do is really sort of go back
to the SAS days right so during the SARS
outbreak investigation we asked the
exact same question what's the reservoir
is a intermediate host involved so I
thought it'd be good to review that
process and to really try to you know
educated the audience to say
scientifically it's going to be a long
process
so during SAS you know the Hong Kong
group led by Professor Guan they isolate
and characterize the virus relate to the
SAS Cornwall's for animals in the market
and civets is one of those okay serious
are the intermediate and transmit hosts
from that paper that's the conclusion
then there's an international group that
I let we eventually you know in 2005 we
identify SAS like crossing bats and we
think that that's could be the natural
reservoir of these fluorisis the
discards based on sequencing and it's
92% identical to the SAS forests
remember the current of that column ours
is 96% identical for the Kobe 19 virus
so our paper published in 2005 actually
identify a bat virus which has a lower
sequence identity to the original SAS
virus but we had a sorority data okay
with a dentist also confirm that the
bats have immune response to SAS lack of
ours but we felt isolated live ours you
know so that's in biology that's a big
sort of a shot coming so and then our
Chinese collaborator so we keep working
there and it took us another eight years
an example in the back in the same came
in you know
prophets eventually we isolate the virus
which is sequence wise is much closer to
the SAS chrono Mars more importantly now
these Mars can use the AC to receptor so
this is the receptor that SAS uses and
Co V 19 viruses uses okay so it took us
more than ten years right of intensive
sampling and international collaboration
to finally get a lot of rust from bats
and to confirm that's how the reservoir
so that's what I try to say is for the
Coby ninety you know I mean everybody
just need to patient scientists need to
do the work properly
and to get conclusive results okay and
you know I just anecdotally put these
slides in the naming pen is for some
reasons the naming the virus is always
controversial and it looks like we could
not get the virus maybe right first time
so 25 years ago when we discovered this
Hendra virus initially recorder equal
morbillivirus because the most related
measles virus and later I was the one
that actually suggests that Hendra virus
because I found that it's not really a
mobility virus it's a new verse and we
said have a new genus in the family of
para mix of artists so for Hendra we
change it from equal mobility to hinder
and for nipple guards initially was
called a hand you're like and then
change it to nipper sauce was a typical
in ammonia and then change the sauce and
mercy initiative was called a human
Kronos pmc and now we know that we had a
name of 2019 and co v now is kobe 19 and
the sauce corn or so so it looks like we
we always need to have a several goes
before we get right and maybe you know
ours at fault because i really start
this mess of naming
viruses mm-hmm so i'm gonna finish our
ways you know really to go to the why
bats topic you know as i said it in the
opening we don't want to demonize bats
because bats have been around much
longer than us yes fax carries a lot of
viruses but there's a real
so I would go through this now first of
all a little bit bad facts right so on
earth now we have around 5,000 living
species of mammals and 20% over a
thousand species of them are facts the
best have been very successful amount of
mammalian evolution and they have some
unique you know features that we don't
have they have a long lifespan so a
seven grand back can live up to 43 years
and they have a low rate of
tumorigenesis just less prone to cancer
and they a result of a large number of
hours especially chrono versus yet they
don't cause disease impacts they just
carry a symptomatic a sort of infection
and then bats are the only flying
mammals you know all the other mammals
are terrestrial mammals we don't have a
flight to fly capability so dealing fly
Bassem attack rate goes fifteen to
thirty four of their resting rate
heartbeat goes can go all the way even
2,000 beats per minute and their body
temperatures you know goes 38 42 degrees
so these are thinking in any of these
happens to human we were die right is
too much stress that our body could not
hand it so during the evolution of bats
obviously they have a change in not only
like the bats of way near the wing is
our fingers you know but also not
morphologically but also physiology
apology immunology they all have to
adapt to this so earlier you know we
switch the from study back bone bars
only to also study back genomics back
biology back immunology
so this is our first paper with partly
2013 and basically we found that there
are two important discoveries that
evolutionally there's strong positive
selection on key in a defense pathways
and these are the DNA damage repair
pathways it's enhanced and the other
sort of a defense paso is it's
inflammation inflammation is reduced
impact
and then how to become extremely healthy
mammal and that's what we believe
bats are very very healthy so I think
that one is that they need to have a
very balanced so the defense not Horan's
is it's important right if it's not
enough defense then you get sick but if
you defense too much you know there is a
cliche that we say in factually is it's
vegetable for virologist suppose we say
very few of our skills as we clear
ourselves
it's that over defense over inflammation
the other side can't stall that's really
caused the severe disease or death
so in bats we have examples all four
elevate in a defense but also
importantly we have samples of dampen in
a defense so that's just get this right
better than us so this is just a diagram
to show that that's what we try to
achieve rather at a healthy status is
that we have a balance you know we have
the defense and we have the tolerance
but if you don't have enough defense
than the tensile cells and the infection
disease piles can grow your body and
especially spent eventually destroy you
but if you have too much then you also
other diseases or autoimmune disease or
you can have died from infection rather
than you know control the infection okay
so a biologic system living organism
whether it's human or bats I think we
can never be perfect because you know we
have individual difference the
environmental good difference the food
we eat the exposure to pathogens and etc
these are all in to affect our daily you
know defense and torrance balance but to
get it right you know you swings a
little bit so I will do this animation
to show that you know for human for
example you sway and eventually get
balanced and for bats it's the same
right they cannot get right in one go
they also have a swing and adjust but if
you noticed right the range of this
adjustment is much smaller in bats and
we think that that's the key that that's
our such a healthy member
so now this is like a translated into
biology so we're talking about defense
genes X Y Z and so on and as you can see
on the left is bad so ma means no
induction and then induce a one induced
to induce a one is a chemical induction
just stress the bass el and induce the
two is a virus infection so this is all
done in cell not in body and as you can
see on the left the bats you know when
you put a stress on the defense gene
goes up but not by as much as human or
Mouse on the right
so the range again right the range of
defense that Horan's is much greater in
human amounts and a smaller impact and
when you have a smaller range you have a
better control and it's unlikely to do
our control and you have less chance to
get disease or death so this is a very
put it very simply of course in the in
biology nothing is as simple as that so
I don't have time to go into you know
the all our discoveries but I'll give
you examples of four of them that
demonstrate that bats have elevates the
base level of defense they have more
efficient DNA damage repaired and they
have a high base level of interferometry
expression and high base level
expression of his shock proteins you
know these are defense protein and a
high base level expression of membrane
pump in the ABC transporters so these
all play different roles in defense but
more importantly we found that in a bats
also have dampened over immune response
especially influence inflammation
there's a whole pathway called an m2
media in from a zone empaths
that's deleted and then other
inflammasome activation is dampened and
there's a molecule very important called
of sting stimulate interferon genes
that's involved in many different
defense pathways bats have it functional
but it's less active than human I did
the last one is the interesting because
that you know we cannot do a lot of
immunology studying bats because the
bats are protected
and very hard to breach so we made a bat
mouths basically we transfer the back
immune system into immunity demise if
you do that for example put a human
immune system into mouth and then
eventually they were developed is called
a graph the versus host disease
so whatever immune system is the
transplant into mice they will see the
mast tissue as pouring and they will
attack that when we did this with the
bat mouse with the Gnostic GVHD you know
this is a very very early observation
but this is important maybe observation
to suggest that bats ability to tolerate
okay so they get this defense and at
horas balance in a much more control so
we recently published a paper about this
infamous ohm dampening as torrents to
bar infection and David Heyman from New
Zealand published a very good sort of a
commentary in nature microbiology and
it's really interesting what he
summarized is is to say you know for
mammals at least that our life
expectancy is proportionate to our body
mass so this the graphene a and you can
see mouse is small so they live shorter
life expenses shorter and humans you
know you know have a big body mass and
our expensi of course is many many years
longer than Mars and then you look back
you know similar body size to Mars but
lives much long so I'm not going to go
through every one of these as you can
see our six graphs right that's on the
line only for B basically to say the
reproductive rate and the life
expectancies so this is the inverse sort
of a proportional you know relationship
so that's our normal in that sense but
in the other five in the other five you
can see for example the graph F right
information and a viral replication you
know so bats again is outlier so bats
are really unique
among mammals and I think that it's the
reason why they are such a good bar
reservoir because they get the tolerance
and the defense right so in summary now
bass is a have a better mu defense and
tolerance that leads to many of
advantage to them okay so they have a
throw aging process and that lead to a
long lifespan they're less prone to
cancer and they carry virus without
clinical diseases right that's why you
know really the focus of my today's
presentation is that why they are such a
good borrow reservoir and they also have
less infirmity disease less autoimmune
years and we now have it and maybe they
also have less metabolic diseases so so
they're just incredible you know memos
and I think there's a lot for us to
learn really so that's you know are they
evil or fortune or severe as I said at
the beginning bats have been around for
you know 60 80 million years much longer
than us and they have Cooley Lewis bars
for a long long time so you know you
think of bats and you think of a Batman
right you know so I think in some
quarters thinking in a Batman for the
savior others thinking the opposite and
then it's really most different cultures
bats are depicted as a duck in or EVO
but in Chinese culture for some reason
that's you know has the same
pronunciation as fortune foo and the
character even is very similar so being
a Chinese you know I believe that you
know bats are good for us it's a savior
and we need to learn a lot from bats and
also that we should not demonize that
all the best carries all these viruses
but if we don't disturb them if the
virus does not transmit to Indymedia
host a human then I think that everybody
is happy all right so that's all I'm
going to
save for this talk and I thank you for
your attention thank you dr. Wong for
your informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen now let's get started
our first question a dr. Wong is why is
it that it bats coronavirus genome or an
animal's corona virus genome
transmission to humans results in
illness and death for humans yes oh I
think that's an interesting question at
first of all I should have qualified to
say we only detected this virus when
they cause disease but they are other
back Renoir's animal cromoz may transmit
a human don't cause disease that we
would not know right so this is a one
area for your audience I have to really
be careful is yes back bone or animal
cornrows can cause disease in human but
not all of them cause disease in human
the ones they don't call this is usually
we don't detect it's below our radar so
to answer your question why they caused
such a severe disease is because that
when Avars jumped your new species and
the new species where respond so like I
said in my talk especially for human and
mouse we tend to over response and when
we over response then we have severe
disease or test when you think of
evolution right virus don't wanna cures
the host there's no advantage it's just
a humans immune response accidentally go
overboard
so I always say you know even for Kobe
90 it's the same it's the lethal you
know about 1% people will die from
infection but it's not the virus for the
virus does know I hear you they want to
propagate inside your body so that most
time when the vast jumped a new host
it's more lethal because the host
response over response if you give it
you know unfortunate maybe that's gonna
happen for Kobe 19 not Lexus we
eradicate in the human population
if the Kobe 19
continue to circulate in human
population most likely it were at that
weight that it would become less viren
because there's no adventure that about
for the bars to kill humans yeah thank
you great thank you so much for that
very informative answer our next
question is why are you almost certain
that there will be more bat coronavirus
stars and MERS outbreak sin the future
yeah so that's what I was a sort of
relate to the first question is we know
that bats carries thousands of
carnivores for some reason that's an
acronym ours is basically just like each
other so they peacefully coexist and
allow the Varsity to really evolve so
there are many many kroner bars so if a
sauce can emerge in a queue and most can
now cuvee 19 can't then there are many
related viruses there and also as I said
you know chrono mounts are jumping
species more often than just these three
okay so my prediction is unless we
change our behavior
don't go destroy the natural habitat of
bats don't stress them and also don't
really you know trade catch trade and
eat wild lives so just keep them in the
natural environment keep them away from
human that's the only way to prevent
them if we don't change our you know a
way of farming trading and eating animal
meat then I think that that it's gonna
happen because we know for a fact there
are so many bars there king nature
yeah thank you great and we're we're
gonna wrap up with this final question
what can we do to prevent future corona
virus outbreaks yeah so I kind of
touched this in the second question is
that I think there's many different ways
we can do it as a whole society that's
what one house concept is very important
right so environmentally we have to
protect their natural habitat and then a
culture of farming wise you know
veterinary
animal scientists we really have to
study you know when the animal gets
dressed and make sure they don't get
stressed and really you know if possible
we have to ban or at least really
regulate wildlife farming in the treaty
in a much much bowel secure about safe
environment just like we do for you know
chicken farming and a pig farming here
and and at the last point then is the
one house that you know scientists like
myself have to work with veterinarians
environmental scientists so proactive
surveillance is another way of
prevention you know so if we see any
risk factors you know for example bat
colonies are too close to a Pangolin or
civets enough army than this
we should advise the government to
prevent that before the VARs job thank
you great thank you dr. Wong do you have
any final comments for our audience yeah
thank you for the opportunity I think
you for your audience first I thank them
for attention you know and secondly I
really cannot emphasize enough is that
bats have been along around longer than
humans right so don't demonize bats you
know because it's not that sport and
also bats could be severe because our
study now is really shifting to learn
how bats can keep themselves healthy
live long and coexist with virus without
disease so maybe they will give us the
keys to unlock some of the mystery of
life and these can be applied to more
than sort of medical research and
eventually benefit human health in
general so with that I like to thank you
and your audience for this opportunity
thank you again dr. Wong for your time
today and all of your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of this
year 2020 lab routes will alert
email when it's available for your
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye